[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm mulling and
I'm Rhett this week at the round table
of dim lighting we have mythical
entertainment employee Matthew who did a
very mythical thing that we're going to
talk about his solo trips to Japan and
Iceland and we'll get into exactly what
we're talking about that very mythical
thing with a very mythical person
extremely fascinating that taps into a
passion of ours which we have written
about in a book yes we have will talk
about that but first we got to keep the
the life blood flowing which the more we
share with you ear biscuit ear
the more we then have to update so it's
like we had this we had this big long
thing about discussion about your um
your throat malady and I know you went
back to the doctor to get a special
scope and it's not that I don't care
about you but you didn't ask anything I
didn't ask
yeah well you didn't ask about my
optometry visit either were you saving I
was saving I was saving it until now
because I want to hear along with the
listeners how it went because your
acquaintance your optometry visit with
my throat visit no I was just saying you
did but you didn't ask me if my vision
changed it didn't it didn't that's not
so since your throat that's so sensitive
of you hi
it's not that I don't think anything's
wrong with your throat I wish I had a
simple answer for you link I wish I had
a simple answer for you the answer is my
throat is not better I did not do that
how convenient I still hear okay good
news bad news
okay why don't I tell you the story
because I went back to the doctor the
doctor that I talked about
on the show did he know you talked about
him was he listening isn't that the
question everybody has so why don't know
as I was driving to the doctor I was
thinking about the fact that the podcast
the podcast was coming out and I had not
yet been to him but there was like a
24-hour period between the time that
podcast came out and he had a wit he
certainly could have listened to the
podcast but yes but to be clear I also
thought about what I said and I didn't I
mean IIIi I didn't throw the guy under
the bus I just I had I told a story
about how I felt that he was posturing a
little bit because he didn't know who I
was and the girls in the office didn't
know who I was
it's something you would never say to
him that then it'd be hard he's talked
about it to a lot of other people that
weren't him he would then probably feel
weird and it might color the experience
you had with him next as a follow-up
procedure yeah yes then I started
thinking about what he was gonna he is
gonna put an apparatus down your throat
he was gonna be doing to me and I was
like well I mean I didn't say anything
offensive and I think if he's if it
based on everything that I know about
the guy maybe he would apologize he's
got like a it seems like he's got a good
sense of humor hmm so he'd probably be
like oh I heard your podcast pretty
funny stuff or something like that like
but all indications when I returned to
the doctor's office where that no one
and still had his head up on it up his
on but no one had listened I'm not going
to say anything no one had listened to
the podcast so apparently they're not
your biscuits fans at the office which
is fine by me but but it was firmly
established that many of them were fans
so well but that doesn't mean you I mean
if you listen to ear biscuits they're
not a true fan of like you that's a
special fan use special listeners
because somebody's seen an episode of
two of good mythical morning I mean who
has all right I'm all right I'm all
right and can't can't bring themselves
to speak to you when they're doing a
medical exam like the nurse could well
we don't need to rehash all that I'm
just saying odds were pretty high
that someone there said hey Doc you
should listen to him yeah I thought
about that so I was scanning every face
when I went back no indication that
anyone had seen it or if they had they
were playing it cool so did you see the
nurse who couldn't speak to you yeah
could she speak to you interesting so
she interesting she did not come in a
different one came in to do my like
initial like evaluation but then when
the doctor came in the same girl from
before came in with him the only thing
this time the girl that won't see me by
herself the girl that will only see me
with the doctor she came back again she
didn't say anything she smiled a lot so
but here this is this basically what
happened so did he get macho he was
super cool like he was honestly he was
like he was super cool and super nice
and like super understanding to the
point that I thought that maybe he
listened and he felt bad like but I also
think that I was reading a lot into the
last time maybe you feel bad and it's
all in my head
well nothing else is all in your head so
how's your throat so he looks at one oh
so he comes in there and he's like okay
I'm like well I've still got the
situation like when I talk for a while I
mean it's happening right now
we just finished you know talking to
Matthew and so it's like there's
irritation but it gets a it's a little
bit better like everyday like but you
know you don't want to go five or six
weeks with a throat problem like you did
it just becomes annoying right so I
wanted to get definitely I want it to be
over with but it's not going away so I
was like I'm still having the issue but
you know it seems like it's getting a
little bit better it's just not going
away fast enough and he's like well I'm
gonna take a look at your vocal cords
which is what you wanted you wanted
definitive proof that there's not some
like nasty polyp growth
fill-in-the-blank on your vocal cords
yeah you're getting what you want
finally yeah I want to know that like
because you know you if you do what I do
and you started reading things on the
internet which is almost always a
mistake especially as it relates to
medical problems you talked yourself
into well I probably have some sort of
irritation that's gonna require vocal
rest whatever and so yeah so he says
okay well I'm gonna look at your vocal
cords and I'm going to do I'm just gonna
use the scope I'm not gonna do the video
scope no video strop which is apparently
this thing where they bring a voice like
a voice therapist in and he they put a
strobe light basically on your vocal
cords and they have you do all these
exercises and then they can analyze the
vocal cords to make sure that you're
using them properly so you're not doing
things that induce damage and he was
like all singers and all voice
professionals should really do this you
know to make sure you're using your
voice but we're not going to do that
today you should come back for that what
I'm gonna do today is I'm gonna use this
little thing basically the thing that
that you had done in the in the plastic
surgery video that we did did you gag
elation so and I was like listen I have
a horrible gag reflex he's like well I'm
gonna do two things I'm gonna spray this
thing in your nose at debt like that
like deadens the nose and I'm going to
spray this other thing that opens up the
passages yeah and so he's like shhh
and boy that was an odd feeling he left
for about 10 or 15 minutes that let it
completely set in and not being able to
feel your nose and the back of your like
top of your throat that's like a
disconcerting feeling and I was like
swallowing and I couldn't feel myself
swallowing it that was like I'm just
like sitting there and the doctor's
office about myself like like the
collecting liken sports swallowing the
clock and chicken worrying about myself
and then he comes in and he's like okay
and he like looks up there he's like
well first of all you have a severely
deviated septum I already knew but the
scope man but he throws in the scope but
the thing about the scope is that if
this if you're set some is deviated it
can be kind of
difficult to get back there we've got a
power through it but he was like I'm
gonna beep I'm gonna push on this thing
and he's like don't worry it's not sharp
but he's pushing on it and he's like oh
it's like hitting nose I'm what look
look and then I can feel it get through
my nose Oh like I I mean I can feel it
in the back of my throat and then I'm
just sitting there and going sound like
an alien you made that noise
and he's like you're doing great I'm
like well I'd like to see the guy who's
not to encourage not feel great I do not
feel as if I'm coming across like I'm
doing great right now and the nurses
taking selfies with you yeah and but
actually I don't think I did that bad
because I eventually mean either quit
making noises and I was able to kind of
go and breathe like that did you do that
thing we like raised one eyebrow
typically only do that in pictures and
so then I am so then he's like okay and
he like pulls it out it feels like
somebody's just pulling something it's
crazy yeah how it feels like a worm yeah
like a camera worm it's like sometimes
like when like you were a kid and you
sort of choked on a piece of spaghetti
yeah and then you pull it out so he says
well the good news is he didn't say that
he was just like there's nothing wrong
your vocal cords he's like they're
inflamed but there's not like damage or
a polyp or a cyst or something like that
he's like they're just inflamed like
it's still inflamed so the bad news
that's great by the way the I mean the
bad news is they're still it's still
inflamed so I was like that he doesn't
have a definitive answer might it be
allergies he was like maybe but then but
that we said might it be a lie
yeah that's how I speak to medical
professionals I use very proper grammar
for though so they'll respect me might
it be allergies allergies doctor might
if he allergies
what we al al al udders is the term that
noses thank you
doc I got one question before I leave
might it be ever so he said maybe it
might be might it be and but night but
that didn't turn into but I'm so I'm
gonna give you some prescription
medication which I don't want more
medication it turned into I'm gonna give
you the bill now yeah wrap this I'm
gonna charge you for this procedure that
I just did and you're gonna go back I'm
bout your life and so but but are you
I'm not now I'm what my worry has
shifted oh yeah oh yeah whack-a-mole I'm
not like worried about vocal cord damage
I'm just worried about well what is it
that's causing this like what is it
really
you're worried about me aren't you is it
you causing it you just how I feel yeah
so but I'm not that worried this is a
preemie supreme it's you know it's
nothing that's permanent or devastating
but no it could be a systemic infection
that's gonna kill me but chances are
pretty small but that's the case but it
is something for you to talk about yeah
all right success well I'm glad I mean
all you got to do is ask man I could
tell you this a couple of weeks ago I
just try to find some peace of mind in
and okay it's good news I'm trying man
that's I went to the doctor but now with
what the doctor told you he found
nothing devastating so let's celebrate
by showing some love to our sponsor
let's do that you can help pay for my
upcoming medical bills by going to
rhettandlink.com/store and getting some
good mythical merch because we're
sponsoring ourselves that's right good
mythical morning original old-school
classic that's the word I'm looking for
a classic merch is available at rent
Lina cop slash store only 40% off if I
said only 40% obese
personnel but it's 40% off 40% off until
it's gone we got the original GMM shirt
this is this is like legacy merch guys
that's a child-size right there if you
want yourself a good mythical logo shirt
get it while the getting's good
rhettandlink.com/store hoodies hoodies
when we see you with it will know that
you were there before it all changed wow
I am happy for I know I've been giving
you a hard time about your your medical
condition but I didn't just put it in
air quotes but I'm you're waiting you
have a problem man
you wait you have a problem thing I'm
not waiting see if I'm if I come around
well you're you're helpful because you
like google it for me you'll fit you'll
figure it out you'll run all the numbers
for me so what I'm trying to say is I
know I've been giving you a hard time
but I'm glad that you don't have
anything god I don't think you feel
really bad but you had some but I don't
think you I don't think we're all the
same page you still feel bad but you
don't have anything you don't have
throat cancer but how could you but no
but how can you if you feel bad you have
something it's cold it's probably
nothing serious yes you have an
elongated cold cold zone last six weeks
where are you going now who are you
gonna see now I'm not going anywhere I'm
gonna stay right here
I want to explain what Matthew does for
us as a member of the mythical crew for
people who don't understand Matthew
thank you for joining us here you are a
solo adventurous and we didn't even know
it so we're gonna talk about that but
I'm interested in having you explain
that
what what what Matt he does I'd like to
see you yeah me too actually I'm very
interested are both of you trying to say
I don't know what Matthew does here a
mythical entertainment no I send you
notes all the time on stuff that you do
like I know it's centered but can you
make it look more centered by uncentered
this so a lot of graphics work very
excited about the branding and
rebranding of lots of things the
inventor of logos mm-hmm so anything
that's graphical that I would not every
single thing we do this graphic yeah but
but a lot of graphic design is to your
credit sir thank you oh yeah I would say
lots of logo work for for mythical and
this is mythical mm-hmm and merge merge
that people don't even know exists yet
has it has low going that you've
invented that's pretty spot-on what do
you think how do you think he did right
he did he I feel like you missed a
pretty big thing which is do other
things too no he found that too right I
know he does it's like what the
massaging is he that much
oh yeah he's not massaging you he's ever
since every Friday man does that just
mean know just why don't you speak up
about the masu scene you've been doing
currently well the other thing that goes
in to what I do as well as I actually do
a lot of the photography here so even
today that was it we were doing a big
photo shoot for new merch that's coming
out and we've gotten to the point where
I've done this enough where Brett's hair
is out of place and I was like I just
I'm just gonna do it and I
I went in there yeah he just got all up
in there but I was lying that was
outside and it made it that massage made
his hair worse yeah I realized I wasn't
good at it and immediately stopped and
then I read no mirror if I appreciate
I've had a weird hair day so I
appreciate it
the other thing that you may have
mentioned this in passing but I mean any
anything that moves on the screen of
good mythical morning that it I did not
mention that yeah that is not us mm-hmm
he's responsible for motion graphics so
you design graphics we're not just
thinking to put them in motion you know
yeah the way I describe it to anyone
else tells me oh what's your job what do
you do I say you know when like words
move on TV and like movies and stuff
that's what I do because when you ever
you say graphics or text people don't
exactly match perfectly picture as a dog
I don't know why what Jade's barking at
I know she's agreeing with me I think
nothing's gonna happen but yeah when you
say graphics or or even taught titles
people aren't exactly picturing but when
I just like words when they move people
are like oh yeah I've seen words move
and words move quite a bit yeah around
here
more more all the time thanks to you
exactly so I love it when words move I
love it when logos come together mm-hmm
another thing that we love is the idea
I'm transitioning here to the idea of
going somewhere solo like solo
adventuring well that's what we're gonna
talk to you about we like it so much
that we we made it a chapter in the book
of mythicality so again redlynx book of
mythicality the book that we have coming
out in October is all about what
mythicality is and you know a
combination of curiosity creativity and
tomfoolery is is what it is but we talk
about how we've experienced that in our
lives and how we try to pursue it and
we've you know I and you through 2010
it's yeah a mythicality is not limited
to the 20 tenets of mythical
are in the book of mythicality but they
are at least equal they at least include
that so and one of those is a chapter
each chapter is a tenant of mythicality
in one of those chapters is isolate
yourself with yourself where we talk
about times that we have personally
attempted to isolate ourselves to find
time alone how important it is to us
both in the past and and and now because
we do think that especially as you know
as we've gotten busier and busier as the
years have gone by there's a lot of
things going on not just our business
slides but also the fact that we've got
families and so you're kind of always
around people and then we're not always
around our families were always around
each other yeah so you begin to value
that time to yourself and in the in that
chapter we trace have you read the
chapter you've seen the book in its and
it's uh I've seen various pieces I've
never really fully seen it okay well
it'll be I will be require something
right yeah because it's not it's not
officially published yet but get on that
train quick buddy because it's leaving
the station I mean I helped kind of
build the Train a little bit so I would
want you graphically designed stuff in
there yeah but we give background about
how over the over our entire lives
we've been anti isolated so we don't
have to go into all those details here
but it brings us to a point where just a
few days ago where we heard you know we
were talking with Cody and Jacob who
helped produce your biscuits and they
just mentioned offhand offhand it Oh
Matthew went to Iceland by himself
on it on it on a trip over the summer
and we're like what I'm so jealous
and one of the things that we want to do
on air biscuits is talk to mythical
people about mythical things that they
have done in our doing and so we found
out that you had manifested a tenant of
mythicality very recently in your life
we were like well let's have a new
biscuit about that and then brings us to
this point but I but I should have said
that you can pre-order the book at book
of mythicality calm yeah you could have
said that yeah yeah I could have
yeah I'll say it if he does book of
mythicality calm see what it feels like
book of mythicality calm book of
mythicality calm there's really no
excuse nothing feels great that doesn't
visit the website so I mean how does how
does one decide to be a solo adventurer
I know you have friends this is not
gonna be a sob story I'm glad you know I
have friends that's good too I don't
think it's just I'm watching you and
your friendships I think it was like a
slow accumulation it was kind of I think
it goes into that bucket list category
in life you know where you always think
about these things or like oh I want to
do that someday yeah and I think it was
that for majority of my life until the
first time I traveled alone which wasn't
Iceland actually I've traveled alone
actually one
internationally one more time before and
I actually went to Japan alone for two
weeks
oh my so that which one should we talk
about first um no it's up to you I mean
I like to work chronologically and I
think it kind of influences kind of why
I did Iceland oh yeah but before that
yeah so are you saying the bucket list
item yeah before that leading up to that
was I want to go to Japan no I'm saying
before I wanted to travel alone I was
like how do you become a person who
knows that they can travel alone or
should travel own I think everybody
should but not everybody does so you
have to that there's something has to
click at some point yeah that's a good
point I think it was it's kind of like
anything else in life and I've tried to
apply this to everything else in my life
that like so many things seem that
you've never done before seem hard or
difficult or oh only sure yeah only
certain people can do this yeah I know
someone has travelled alone and
done this before but they're they're
more brave or crazy whatever you want to
apply to them no matter what it is but I
think it was a combo of things I
actually have a close friend who
traveled alone like he actually skipped
college like took a bunch of years off
after high school and travelled Central
America alone traveled around Israel in
the Middle East alone traveled India
alone and I that was definitely a big
factor for me was you know I went to
college and we stayed in touch and
whatnot and so I kind of followed his
journey you know alone through the world
and that made like that lit that item on
my bucket list just get bigger and
bigger and bigger that's like I have to
do that I have to dry this I have to try
this sometime I knew people that got
married and had kids and it sounds like
a joke but especially the kids part like
it and hanging out with kids right Jill
it's like oh I can't I think I could I
think Christian and I we could have kids
like I know that's how it happened with
visit visit like I believe we've we may
have children I remember hanging out
with people with kids and I was like
they can't they're doing it this is what
it's like and it's they can do it mm-hmm
maybe I can do it we should we should
give it a shot we shouldn't wait until
we feel like we've got it figured all
out to have a kid but I never met anyone
who traveled anywhere solo so I never
thought I could do that - mm-hmm life
could have been so different you had a
friend yeah so I think that was one
factor right there
but then the other factor was I did get
to travel a good amount with my family
as I was growing up we want to I went on
a lot of trips with my brother my sister
my dad especially but those were you
know family trips whether their road
trip down to Florida or flying to San
Francisco to visit an aunt and it was
always a family trip led by my dad which
I will say my dad is one of the best
travelers I know in life period you know
he's very organized
he's very Pro itinerary or at least when
he was traveling around with us all
under the age of like 15 like he had
had to be on top of everything mm-hmm I
mean he always seemed to know exactly
what we were doing what we were going to
do next and like which is always keeping
the time schedule for things let's his
name Rick Steves
no just Michael Dwyer but close enough
you know Rick Steves Rick Steves Europe
was one of my favorite shows he's a
traveler man yeah he likes to over in
Nazi I wouldn't want to be my dad though
yeah the socks in the sandals wouldn't
would have worked
yeah but yeah so did your dad wear socks
with sandals like Tino's no what's oh no
ain't no self-respect person does that
he was an itinerary man and he was a
cyclist Evo wearing traveler exactly or
did he wear like chocolate or chocolate
are my mispronunciation and inevitably
of those fancier Tevas that have more
straps I don't go down that oh we're
talking about the sandals that aren't
flip-flops that had the multiple
strategy strappy strappy yes he wears
those but no no socks no socks oh cool
yeah go ahead
you're glad two feet but anyway tchard
all my experiences with travel before
were with my family which I loved and
everything but I think the number one
thing I associated what the was lack of
control I think it's the best way to
describe was like I was being brought to
these places I wasn't necessarily
choosing to go and I think that was one
of those things that I just always
thought about was like oh I want to be
able to go on a trip but I'm in charge
and see what that's like without my
family or anybody else yes no companions
mm-hmm well that is a I mean being in
control and then going companionless
going solo that's still a bit of a leap
mmm no did it take more than just the
guy who who did it to say I thought is
now in my head I think then me time
would I like made the hard decision like
went online bought plane tickets was
actually it was 2014 and I had already
decided I was going to move to Los
Angeles at the time I was looking
where I grew up and where I was living
Milwaukee Wisconsin and I had already
made the decision I was gonna move to LA
and I've been saving up for well over a
year and I kind of realized I'd saved up
more than I had planned and then also
realized like oh I could I could go on
that trip like I have enough money that
I could budget out a trip and I
especially knew the second I moved to
Los Angeles them like I wouldn't yeah I
wouldn't think to travel outside the
country alone while I was living in Los
Angeles trying to find a job mm-hmm
so I and I had already had you had some
money stashed away you had a window of
time mm-hmm
and it was kind of a okay so I also see
there's a little bit of a clean break
like when you moved from Milwaukee to LA
was that just you did you even know
anybody out here I knew three people
maybe that would be out here but you
didn't move out with him no mm-hmm okay
and so that was the thing was I already
knew I was gonna move out alone all
right new I want to live alone in LA and
so it was I don't think anybody could do
that nobody can afford to live alone in
LA I
I mean spoiler alert I have a roommate
now okay but and that was my plan and I
think I was a compilation of those like
big life choices whereas already like
I'm gonna move halfway across the
country already
you know like almost wanted to kind of
prepare was like okay and I'm gonna
travel so it wasn't what you were moving
to LA and then you just severely
overshot it and ended up in Japan for
two weeks well cuz I also realized if I
was gonna Bly excuse me if I was gonna
buy plane tickets to LA to find an
apartment anyway I could actually save
money on a ticket thank Lee if I flew to
Japan stay in Japan for two weeks then
flew from Tokyo to LA stayed in LA for a
week to find my apartment and then flew
back to Milwaukee to then drive back to
LA to move so it was like all part of a
round-trip with a long delay a little
layover exactly it explains why you had
more money you didn't know about coz
here you got it you got you got this
financial thing figured I know exactly I
was like oh technically I'm saying like
that was the excuse I tried to
is that why you chose Japan because it
worked out in the the la route or was
there something specific about Japan
that you'd always want it to experience
I for a good portion of my life as I
have always been interested in Japan I
would say probably the seed of that kind
of goes to my childhood of Pokemon and
getting into anime so that was
definitely a very good gateway into
Japan and learning about Japan so it was
kind of just over time from that since I
was like nine of like learning more and
more about Japan outside of it even just
pop culture that I just got more and
more interested in it and I did start
with the basic thing of like I want to
travel outside outside of the country
alone where do I want to go to do that
for the first time and I literally I
think I did open up Google Maps and then
just I looked at the map of the world I
zoomed all the way out and was just like
where do I want to go and like I guess
you did a POV satellite I didn't like
wish list basically I didn't do like
Google Earth like I didn't get out too
far like I just you didn't become an
astronaut yeah this decision-making
yes but yeah this is a this is a
mythical thing to do yeah it really is
you know it's it you open Google Maps
and just zoomed out as far as I've ever
done that but what you threw a dart was
something I absolutely love to do and
I've never taken action on this is I
mean everybody I'm anybody who's ever
had a globe has done their thing where
you spin the globe and like I'm gonna
close a little put my finger on the
globe and wherever I land I'll go water
in the ocean all lost but the idea that
you did it with an intention to follow
through and it was about I mean even the
whole process was well it was about the
process it was about the journey not the
destination because he didn't have it
yet you were like mm-hmm
I'm gonna go somewhere I'm gonna go
alone I know I know how I'm gonna do
something but I don't yet know what it
is mm-hmm which
is actually another chapter we talked
about in the book you probably don't
even read it really quit selling this
book no just read the book just ready
but it is very mythical and it's you
know it's so you zoomed out mm-hmm and
you saw and I did a general did a
general scan and honestly I think one of
the first things that popped out to me
was Japan and it was kind of one of
those things were almost first idea best
idea where was just like I couldn't get
out of my head like I kept on looking
around kept on hemming and hawing like I
almost tried to think about like
continents to where I was like okay well
no we're in North America or even South
America because that's basically part of
North America so like let's really go
for it let's go and then I had actually
been outside the country before again on
another family trip with my dad where we
went to Ireland so then I kind of
canceled I was like okay then no Europe
Tennant like wherever I like farthest
away I would then been there done that
yeah on it and I think it yeah all
scientists pointed to Japan and it made
me immediately excited and that's really
just how I knew and then when you so you
you timed it with moving to LA and then
but when you got there did you have a
dad like itinerary and more importantly
I'm curious how much did you talk
because the way that I think about like
solo trips is that they're like silent
retreats where you find yourself not
talking to anyone instead when making
like some sort of exchange mm-hmm yeah I
mean I think yeah that's one of the
first questions a lot of people ask
especially depending on where you're
going and so far I would say Iceland and
Japan haven't in common where it's
pretty easy to travel when you're only
an English speaker and Iceland actually
even easier than Japan probably but for
the most part like a lot of major signs
are and you know what you imagine when
you imagine Japanese and the Japanese
characters but then there's also Roman
letters basically it's so phonetic
written out the Japanese words and you
know so you can actually read it so yeah
but not necessarily English what do you
mean yeah so lives but not English so
rumblers an ABCD like ABCD efg doesn't
English word what but you could say Rome
you got her now you could pronounce it
somebody Veneto like what you were
talking about oh it's like using English
to tell you how to speak Japanese but
for most words that works
however the neighborhood where I stayed
the first night did not play so this is
probably a good example so literally I
landed Japan it's over I can't remember
anymore but it was like a 12 to 14 hour
flight I land in Japan and I did have a
plan for the most part like I did try to
be really prepared
I booked ahead of time where I was
staying where I stayed in hostels which
is you know the affordable way portable
way to travel on a budget which means
you you share restrooms with strangers
and sometimes you share cots with
strangers usually it's not cots it's
maybe like a bunk bed scenario but
usually you keep to your own bunk
that's unless you know I think movies
you've been one yeah if anything it's
maybe there's some consensual sharing
but other than that it's I know you get
assigned each a little bit but yeah etc
yeah basically you're kind of in like
done sound hostel at all you're
basically in like larger size dorm rooms
that usually are at least like six bunk
beds and then yeah it's like a communal
communal bathroom with you know a bunch
of sayings bunch of showers oh yeah
so I knew it you were phonetically
sounding out signs and it didn't work
out yeah so the neighborhood and also
like the name of my hostel had the name
of the neighborhood which was I'll just
say what it was spelled so it was a sa
kusa how would you pronounce that Hey
okay I say so I pronounced it and
thought was pronounced like how retro
sate Asakusa cuz I was just looking at
phonetically and like I had actually
been trying to learn some basic Japanese
like hello excuse me
you know that's my bunk
yours I didn't think to do that one I
didn't get that far
we're in my bunk where I thought with me
where I thought like I could print out
if I saw a word I'd be able to read and
relatively pronounce it correctly I
thought but you know I got gotten from
the airport to one of the like the main
train stations in in Japan as are in
Tokyo and so but it's a big train
station and it's one of those things
where there's a bunch of turnstiles and
different parts of the building and I'm
not sure how to get to the next train to
take me to my hostel so are you using I
mean this is 2014 right this is a 24 mm
I have a smartphone right so one of the
things that we noticed in our recent
trip to New York because we haven't
really been to New York and navigated on
our own and in a number of years like
we've been going for work and it's like
you're in a car and somebody else is
worrying about where you're gonna be but
the last time I actually went to New
York and like navigated the subway
system well that was 99 right by printed
map not by yeah Google yeah and you had
the map in your pocket but like now with
the smartphone it was like I wasn't
thinking about anything so how did that
how does that translate to Tokyo well
and that's that's the thing again we're
like at times especially in these
scenarios like it feels like a cheat
code where a lot of problems can easily
be answered by the smartphone and Google
Maps is really great like it translates
everything so like it shows everything
and the English for in the English
version but it's mark as it hooks up to
the public transit system just like in
New York City you know it shows the name
of lines does like colored icons to show
you like the different lines and whatnot
but it's still you know I think it's
still like this word doesn't say
breakdown of like oh there's multiple
floors to this station and here's how
you get to that line you know all you
know all I knew was I was in the right
building but I didn't know where the
hell in the building to go
where is Asakusa yeah and so Asakusa and
so I and there's and so I went to one of
the help desks and I still was
speaking English because like everyone
at those helped us and like especially
anyone of like Authority that you really
need to talk to most likely at least
knows a little bit of English if not is
pretty fluent and it was funny because
immediately the second I said it like
they looked at me like I was crazy
and so all of a sudden I just knew I was
second-guessing everything I had done
where I was like did I write down wrong
am i action like what did i do what did
I do wrong until finally the person that
was helping me like like realizes like
Oh sucks ah sucks I was like yes and
then like explaining me of like oh you
have to go through multiple turn Styles
where I thought like I would be like
double charged to go through that I was
like afraid to leave but I had to go
through a couple turn Styles to then go
down to another floor to get on the
train I had to get to finally got to my
hostel after I think it had been like a
full 20 hours like from like ooh Houston
Airport to Tokyo like to my actual
hostel was like maybe almost like 20
hours and I was just like spent but then
I walk in and you know it's maybe I
think it's almost like a let it was
almost 11:00 or like midnight there's
someone behind the desk and like they
checked me in and they me the last like
oh do you want some tea and they
literally give me like a nice like cup
of like iced green tea and I take a sip
and I swear to you it was one of the
best green teas I've ever had like
everything immediately like all the
stress of like travel I like melted away
and got that confidence boost you'll
never have a green tea that good again
yeah and then almost immediately went to
my room and passed out now were the
people it was a Saku say did that
actually mean something nasty yeah
that's important figured out how to do
that did what kind of people are in
these hostels is are we talking mostly
Westerners that are traveling around I
mean that is a good chunk I would say in
Japan there were a fair amount of people
from
or Taiwan to but I would say it's it's
predominantly Westerners whether it's
the US or Canada or you know UK parts of
Europe mm-hmm no no by themselves - I'm
trying to think if I actually met yeah I
did meet a couple people who were
traveling together now but my question
about talking to people was not actually
about the language barrier it was about
literally socially connecting with
people I mean do you consider yourself
an introvert extrovert where are you on
the scale I mean if you're in a hostile
situation
are you are you like talking to people
and making friends or is your goal to
kind of be a monk like with a vow of
silence and you're like Travel
experiencing Japan on mute I really took
a day to day and I think that goes again
to the idea of like because I'm
traveling alone I can do whatever I want
talk to whoever I want not talk to
whoever I want and all right are you an
introvert or extrovert have what would
you say and I think that definitely
leans more towards introvert if I like
really had to choose between the two and
I think that's what's nice is at least
like if you know if I feel comfortable
enough then you know I can be more
extroverted but I think that's what was
nice about the hostels where you can
usually kind of tell by you know the
second you walk into your dorm and say
someone's already there whether or not
they're in the mood to talk or chat you
know just by how whether or not they
even say hello to you or like it's just
like a head nod kind of like when I sit
down in a in like a hairstylist chair
and I immediately just close my eyes
like that's the guy I do not want to to
interact with you I think that's
actually probably like the best analogy
is it's when you go into a new barber
especially like the within the first two
seconds you both agree like whether or
not you're gonna have a conversation so
I do this weird thing where I talk to
him for like seven minutes and then I
guess then eyes closed I I talked to him
I have the friendlies and that's all I
got that's all I want ya next time
I tried just closing my eyes and see
what happens so do you have like a
trying to picture you you have like a
backlight on air in like they would like
what is your outfit you got like a
tracksuit when we get travel clothes
right yeah he's dead
I'm definitely picture you in a
tracksuit well you would have to picture
me without facial hair because this is
before facial hair okay gum but I
I packed relatively light I did couldn't
grow facial hair three years ago well I
did I had the end of the trip I did it
I'm trying to think like I packed like
pants one pair of shorts and maybe I
think that most I did like maybe like
five shirts but it was like meant to be
like layers like couple t-shirts and I
did and I got one shirt from REI which
was like breathable ones one of those
breathable ones but like at like first
glance you wouldn't think of like oh
that's like one of those like squishy
sound e material like things like it
looks like a normal collared shirt for
the most part what you mean but it's got
those cool like side roll-ups vents yeah
I like so much like a fly fisherman
shirt this is like legit camping sure
man like I would never go to oh yeah
okay it's like a cool I mean it looks
like it's like I've almost forgotten one
like 700 times I've got to guilty for
never hiking or doing anything REI ish I
still continue to wear this shirt like
around when I'm not oh I didn't even
notice
exactly exactly what about the pants you
have zip off no I didn't I didn't go
that far either have I had one pair of
shorts on one pair of jeans okay but you
can get what he can get one pair that's
it both of them yeah and I was Chari I
zip off at the knees yeah man I want
some of those too I wore those and buddy
system season one I think I still got
him around here but I don't do stuff
that needs it the last time I wore like
zip off pants was like I was like 10
years old haha they're glorious man I
don't know if I can go back office stuff
they are versatile I don't know if
they're glorious yeah okay so you're
dressed you you're pretty legit you
dress privileged it not a lot of clothes
yeah like what's it like a typical day
typical day again I think how I plan my
trip was not so much an inch
an array of like oh I have to be here at
at noon because I have to be at this
place at 4:00 p.m. right on the dot like
I treated more as like I made a list of
just like top things let's see if I can
do these things today and like in just
order of importance we're like I
absolutely want to do this one thing
today I want to make sure I do that but
then a couple other ideas and then just
structure the day out that way so I
think the first day I went to Akihabara
which is like a neighborhood that's just
very well known for its like video game
stores and video arcades so it's like
classic of like what you kind of imagine
with Tokyo which is like super tall
buildings and like tons of people on the
sidewalk crossing streets just like
people everywhere entertainment overload
yeah so I went there first I went there
first and you know what walked around
when his stores went into an arcade
played some games it was kind of hard to
play they play the games because again
not a lot of English in the actual games
but I was able to like put money in hit
start and play and know that I lost so
which is the point exactly yeah I did
that and like wandered and purposely
like wandering around because that's
like a thing that I really love about
traveling and being a new place is like
putting that time in to wander and to
like explore and just just walk around
and find yourself somewhere yeah exactly
what was the best Japanese experience
and the worst like was there a worse
thing like did you get mugged and what
was the best thing did you like get
married I have to think on the worst
thing because I might it might be just
like the first experience of like trying
to find my own I lost all that ever
great if you if you don't have that's
best that's really hard to say it's a
combo of a lot of things I think the
number one thing I always talk about
with Japan is definitely the food yeah
God like I I was going through my phone
everywhere or one place like just the
everywhere everywhere like I was going
through my photos to prepare for this -
you know refresh my memory I have so
many photos of just like food in my hand
cuz I was like while I was heinous I
want to remember this now are you
adventurous eater I have as I've grown
as I've gotten older cuz you can't go
you can't go to gym and be like I don't
like fish man I don't I'm not really
into fish mm-hmm boo fish yeah and I
already like really like Japanese food
in general but I think one of the things
that stuck out to me was I finally
googled it to figure out what was
actually called because I couldn't
remember I I walked up to this stall
that was outside of this temple near my
hostel and they had these rotten these
things these fried crispy things that
had delicious filling in them and like
that's what they were in my head the
entire time until I finally I figure out
what they were called is they're called
aku Manju which is basically like
steamed buns if you've had those before
which is no a bread with you know round
roll size with like you know smooth
sweet fillings in it or different savory
fillings but but then it was dipped in
tempura batter and fried you stay fair
that was like that was my breakfast
almost like my entire first week in
Tokyo was like I would go to that stall
and I got like a bunch of different
flavors like like he had green tea
flavored we're like they even flavored
the breading to like the tempura batter
was a lot much of flavoured along with
the filling inside like and they had
like sweet potato flavor like yam flavor
they had like black sesame flavored
that's one of the things I remember the
most of all like I got that a bunch when
um so yeah there were two weeks there
two weeks the closest I have to like a
solo adventure is one summer I think you
were this was in college I went to
Nashville to visit our friend Josh I
think you were in Slovakia that summer
and I was I was that I'm taking summer
classes and I took one week and I went
to Nashville to visit him but he was
working so every day during the week he
would give me his car and I just you
know for so for that eight hours he was
working I was just going around
Nashville all alone and it was the first
time
that may be the only time that I've had
like a that much time to myself and I
was really excited at first and I went
to the town first I went to the Country
Music Hall of Fame
oh yeah who's not excited and I and I
walked around like slow pace like no
one's rushing me and reading all the
play I ready I guess I can read every
play and then after a while it's lightly
Lovelace is boots I don't need to read
everything flash I'm reading about Patty
Loveless boots right now I'm not a Patty
Loveless thing just the third pair of
Patty Loveless boots that I've checked
out I went outside and I had a pack with
some water in it of course and I
remember I would um I'd like I sat
outside of the museum and then I a few
minutes later I laid down no I went to
sleep in the museum no outside ok I will
call it a park ok like trees outside of
the museum I took a nap like on a guitar
bench and then I got up and I'm like
walking around and driving around and
then the next day I've you know hang out
with Joshua and I mean the next day I go
into town to Nashville I'm like on Music
Row I'm like I've heard about Music Row
where all the Nash the Nashville sound
I'm gonna take my water down to Music
Row and just drink so here I am just
drinking water walking down Music Row
and I you know I found a little a little
Park to sit down for a few minutes and
then then I laid down and then was lots
of sleeping I went to I was asleep and I
realized that I was becoming a homeless
person
what Nashville the third day that's how
it begins if you don't have or if you
don't have every return trip if I don't
have an itinerary I just start sleeping
in public places by the by the fifth day
the last day that Josh was at work he
had a pool at his house I'm just I'm
just gonna stay here at the time we'll
stay here and sleep water and a place to
sleep I got on a float in the middle of
the pool I fell asleep
woke up with the worst sunburn you could
ever deserve every bit of it yeah what a
what a jerk you know it's like Here I am
I could explore this whole city in a
slight way I got tuckered out I got to
go to the pool so burnt the next day we
went hiking and it was like my collar
bones were so burnt that I couldn't
swing my arms because it would hurt and
I was absolutely bona fide miserable you
didn't know you didn't know what to do
with myself it was a different time
because that same summer I was in
Slovakia and you know most of I was over
there with a lot of college students and
like our itinerary was pretty much
figured out with what we were doing
right but it's funny I haven't thought
about this until right now and now we're
talking about it in this context but one
of them fell asleep fell asleep in a
pool I'm going to no we would have some
days that we didn't have any
responsibilities and we were like
teaching English at these four slow box
and when we didn't have to do that you
could do whatever you wanted to and my
inclination was I mean sometimes it
would be like oh there's a couple of
people that I've kind of gotten to know
a little bit better I'll go do something
with them but my disposition was almost
always to be like I'm just going to go
off by myself today which a day is a
free day and I would just walk like the
city so I'm being like Oh she'd say
Slovakia and I would just walk around
did you ever lay down and sleep never
did you sleep you're human like I didn't
I can't sleep in I can't barely sleep in
a bed man I'm just worrying can i
clarify it you keep on saying sleep do
you mean just sleep and determine him
out or like nap like in a quick 15 it
would easily be 45 minutes Wow okay like
an eye if a naps worth taking is worth
taking but I take it all the way but the
inclination to just go off and beat but
I but I still I'm just kind of walking
around
mm-hmm I wasn't in Tokyo that's that's
for sure
all right you sent me a postcard from
there and it was two polar bears mating
yeah because they do that that's how
they made little polar bears I wanted
you to understand how what I was
learning I hope you just thought it was
funny it was wasn't it you remember it
it was your honor into this day would
you it was funny would it be better if
they were sleeping yeah well they sleep
after well they sleep that yeah I was
like those polar bears sleep in a weird
position then I turned over and Rhett
was like dear link let me tell you how
little polar bears flip over so it was
that was so three three years later you
take a solo trip to Iceland so was there
a solo trip in between there was no I'm
working you so hard yeah and you haven't
been able to get away well yeah so after
three years after like what I would say
is like one of the best trips I've ever
taken and it was it wasn't lone you know
I always kind of told my head like oh I
wanna you know work hard enough to get
to the point where like I can be able to
do another trip like this and I gotten
to that point where I decided like okay
this summer while gmm is on hiatus I'm
gonna do another trip a solo trips
isoelectronic yeah another soju I'm
saving up for a solo yeah and what was
it not specifically about Japan or but
what the solo aspect was it like I mean
obviously you know and also you know
three years later three years old or
life changes you changes in person was
there this because so many things would
have to be like worked out in my life
personally for me to take a solo trip
like I don't you know it's like yeah
that'll happen anytime soon yeah but it
would be like this is going to be some
sort of deeply contemplative experience
if I were to like do this something like
having done it once did you approach it
differently and it was like what the
yeah the purpose of it well yeah like
because I had played with this idea of
this trip which what I thought was like
say not the most planned out trip not
like the most like hard I
in ireri trip that I felt like a I felt
again like oh maybe I want to play this
more and like leave you have even happy
to be more open more free to like have
time to do what I do what I want do
whatever and and because and because
like I did really enjoy the experience
of traveling alone it because it goes
back into all those things of control
like I did whatever I wanted you to hate
wherever whatever I want you know and I
think that was the same idea where like
and there's no necessary worries about
like what's going on back home or
whatever or anything like that it's like
it's about being present for a specific
amount of time and so yeah I wanted to
do that again and I knew I wanted to do
another international trip I mean I'll
be honest like it's really hard for me
to just not go back to Japan like every
time I think about doing I could just go
back to Japan and like because there I
still barely saw like I don't know like
I small I saw a small percentage of the
country like I stayed in Tokyo for one
week in Kyoto for another week and did
kind of day trips taking the train a
little bit outside the outside those
areas before the most part I was in
central Japan like I didn't see any of
like the south or the or the north and
so like there's play more that I could
have see it and like I'm kind of still
trying to force myself like no part of
it too is to also experience something
new every time like them taking that
time out I want to do that opportunity
to do something new and so part of why I
picked then picked Iceland was because
usually I realized like when I think
about traveling like I always think more
about cities and stuff like I'm always
first at thinking like ah be really cool
to go to Hong Kong really cool to go to
Berlin like I don't think like oh would
be cool to go to China it'd be cool to
go to Germany I think more like in city
terms so I realized like Iceland would
be a good opportunity to once again push
me out of my comfort zone of like oh
this is a trip where you're not it's
kind of weird to like to stay in
Reykjavik for a week and not go outside
the city limits of Reykjavik which is a
pretty small city when like there's so
much like just nature to see in Iceland
I think that's probably the biggest
number one attracting attractive thing
for that country is the
beautiful like natural splendor but it's
a stark contrast to the populace of
Tokyo yes
so was that another factor was now I'm
going solo to somewhere where I could I
could actually stay solo yeah like where
I could literally be at the edge of like
a waterfall and just be the only one
yeah which I had imagined in my head and
thought was a possibility once I got
there a little less likely okay
because tourism and Iceland and in the
like the last five years especially has
just like exploded it's a population
maybe three hundred thousand and now
they see about two million tourists a
year okay which is insane because it
just it's become very popular for I
think a lot of reasons I think partially
because it's so so beautiful that Ben
Stiller movie Ben Stiller movie what was
that movie I skateboarded water MIDI
Walter Mitty silly bordered across
Iceland mmm-hmm weirdly I think I did
see that that movie came out around the
time that I went to Japan actually
oh yeah thinking about it but and also
Game of Thrones I think is also like
they film a lot of locations there but
yeah the main track detector thing for
me was like okay this trip forces me to
go outside my comfort zone and go out
into nature and so I planned out my trip
where got tickets and I rented a car and
I drove around say like a third or like
half of the country in a week in one
week in one week and what were there
hostels where were you what was the main
thing you were doing seeing sights
hiking just trying to survive in the icy
depths of all the above I mainly stayed
in hostels in one night I stayed in at a
Airbnb I thought I was going to do a
decent amount of hiking but kind of how
my trip went canceled that fact for
whatever reason my first 24 hours in a
country like really say a lot about the
so I landed in Iceland and stayed in
Rick stayed in Reykjavik that night I
got I kind of you know wandered around
the city for the most part that night
the next morning I was driving a
probably the longest distance almost
like three or four hours to my Arabi
that I was staying at that night and I
was maybe the neck so my second day I
was maybe barely 20 minutes outside of
Reykjavik and I and kind of how Iceland
is laid out there's what's called the
Ring Road which is basically only like
two lanes but it goes around the entire
island mm-hmm and it but it's not like
normal like American highways where you
know you know there's maybe some curves
but you know stuff can be straight it's
all like windy and curvy and but then
there's just beautiful things that like
every turn you make and I pulled over
because I'd seen I saw a beautiful
mountain and I was like I gotta take a
photo in front of this and I pulled over
to the side of the road and I did a very
touristy thing where I'm trying to take
a photo of myself and I fell into a
ditch you you you were taking a selfie
basically yeah like a big ditch like a
big enough ditch where was this afjord
technically nah I don't think that's
there no oh no there's fjords there are
few words oh yeah there's plenty few
words oh that's right where I thought I
thought Oh greener than Greenland so
take a bite out of that dude was very
great but I fell into this very green
ditch and how deep was this dish what is
at least four feet maybe five feet was
her ice in the bottom no what happen so
I did you die so I hurt I hurt my ankle
like where I got out I cut I climbed out
of the ditch I'm sorry I'm I laughed at
myself it's so I got out and like it was
painful getting out both to my pride and
my ankle and so I'm standing up and I'm
out of the ditch and I realize when I
put weight on my ankle it hurts
like oh crap I mean I I mean I'll just
get on the car I'm getting the car and
sitting I can put some weight off it
it'll probably be fine
I get back in the car and I start
driving
but then as I'm sitting with no weight
on my foot it starts to hurt and like
every mile I'm driving it just hurts
more and more and more and I guess but
no luckily is my left foot and I I kept
trying to like pull over because there's
a lot of spots especially along the Ring
Road to pull over and take photos of
just beautiful landscapes like it's not
like rest areas in America where like oh
there's bathrooms and picnic tables and
stuff in the most part most of them are
like maybe a miniature parking lot they
can fit like five five ish cars and
maybe a picnic bench and maybe a sign
explaining that area but then that
that's it and like there were so many
was so many beautiful spots and like I
slowly had to just keep on driving past
them because I got to the point where
it's like I need to I I need ice I'm in
Iceland my ankle hurt my device my ankle
hurts and I need ice which I was in
Greenland so I pull out my phone I
pulled over pulled out my RV humor and I
try to find like the nearest what seemed
like okay this is a big gas station they
should have everything I could possibly
need you know whether it's you know
bandage wrap or something or just
aspirant something so so I pull over and
I get out of the car for the first time
in like maybe two hours and I'm
immediately limping like you swallow me
and I and I looked I looked at my ankle
for the first time - with like my sock
off and my ankle had like swollen up
like and I literally like hobbled into
this gas station and immediately
realized the biggest irony of Iceland
it's really hard to get ice and I saw
there was no ice like they had every
possible like bottled drink and stuff
but there was no ice no ice packs no
nothing it was still like a convenience
store
they had other stuff like car fresheners
and stuff like that but they're like
medical medicine Isle was basically
toothbrushes toothpaste and feminine
hygiene products like that was it you
could freeze that now what did you use
what does this does the clerk speak
English they do they do
um and I and I asked like do you have
ice packs and and it was a bit of a
surly Icelandic teenager he was like oh
no sorry and so I bought a water bottle
and left immediately started googling
pharmacies found a pharmacy drove to a
pharmacy and it was what I thought what
it was like you know Iceland's main
chain of pharmacies their equivalent of
like say Walgreens and I walk in and
it's laid out like what I would call
more of like an old-timey pharmacy where
every single pill is behind the counter
like every pill and I talked and I
talked to the actual like pharmacist in
a white coat and like I I thought I was
being so smart was like I'm not gonna
say Tylenol not gonna say advil no brand
names aspirin aspirin has to be like a
universal one and I said like I need a
spur and he looked at me like I was
crazy like like why could I possibly
need aspirin even though I've limped
into this pharmacy maybe she thought I
need something better than aspirin but
finally she said like Oh aspirin okay
and pulled up a bottle and I bought a
bottle of Icelandic aspirin that was all
like all the directions were in
Icelandic not English finally takes some
get back in my car get to my Airbnb
where I was renting a room in this
woman's house and so I pull up she's out
front and I limp out of my car and
explain like I hurt my ankle I fell in a
ditch do you have ice she didn't have
ice think you are III don't know where I
thought I was but she did not have ice
luckily the bar nearby her house had ice
she went to go get me ice and I got set
up in my room in her house put my foot
up with a backup ice and about six
Icelandic aspirin in my stomach
and then just chilled out for the rest
of the day and I remember thinking like
I really hope I don't have to actually
go to the hospital like I didn't think I
broke it
like I really thought it would hurt more
immediately if I broke it but it was
still like unbearable pain where like if
I I knew like I couldn't walk more than
like a couple feet that was that great
start so that was the start of my trip
that was like within the first like 48
hours of my trip and but then I got up
the next morning and my ankle felt
immediately better oh wow where I could
I could put weight on it
I could actually ascend the stairs to
get to the only bathroom in the house on
my feet instead of going up step by step
on my butt which is what I had done the
night before I was just weird American
yeah and but my host Medoc Madera like
God god bless her she had breakfast out
for me the next morning with like a
bunch of different jams and cheeses and
stuff and like she made me tea once
again like I think the best way I know
like someone's a good tourist experience
is when someone else makes you tea in
another country I know what it is about
it and I'm so then you were able to go
from there and see a lot of Iceland
which I'm sure was was breathtaking yeah
and I got a lot of advice from my host
about what to do and what to see and the
rest of the trip just got better and
better my ankle got better and better
and the trip got better and better I
think for these solo trips I mean what
was your expectation and then what was
your takeaway in terms of was there kind
of a goal of either was it just rest was
there like a an aspect of introspection
to this I mean so as a person did you
come away as a better person or what
what's the takeaway well yeah I think
that's why these two trips kind of go
hand in hand and that with Japan part of
what I went into it was hoping that it
would help prove to me too that like not
only okay if I can go to this foreign
country for two weeks alone I can move
across the country and live in Los
Angeles alone was kind of mm-hmm the
idea I kind of had in the back of my
head and I came out of it feeling that
confidence like it was kind of a bit of
a confidence but it said like okay I was
able to navigate this country I can
navigate the city and then when I went
to Iceland and maybe think like well oh
I've already got this one trip on her
under my belt I can do this alone too
and I would say like well I love my trip
in Iceland I think if if I go back to
Iceland I will definitely have a
co-pilot oh really yes yes absolutely
because not just in scenarios where you
say sprain your ankle and you still have
to drive yourself across the country but
what but there was like a lot more times
where especially because it's a lot of
it is so Road Trip focused like there
are just times where I was like man I
really just want to stare out the window
right now and I can't I didn't have the
control I wanted were like I had to
focus on driving like I couldn't choose
between the two where I think especially
with like the different types of things
are doing Iceland like it makes sense to
like have some form of co-pilots also I
saw a lot of couples in Iceland and it
like hammered home way more than in
Japan like I saw everybody's with
somebody and that's that okay so there's
there's there's a desert opening are you
saying there's an opening for a
companion to go go back to Iceland with
you sorting into maybe guys have to be
honestly there's a reason why I came
here I mean even those things being said
I mean there's it wasn't an enriching
experience absolutely when you look at
the two of them together and you say
okay this is about me figuring out who I
am and what I'm capable of and I'm like
if I find myself in a ditch am I gonna
be able to get out of it yeah
metaphorically speaking of course of
course that doesn't actually happen yeah
would you recommend solo adventuring in
general in terms of like the building
blocks of a person yes but that can be
solo adventure and can be anywhere
though I don't think it's a caveat where
like
Oh everyone has to travel outside the
country because not everyone has that
ability or that privilege to be able to
do that but I think for the most part
most adults have the ability to do
something alone and do an adventure
alone and I absolutely recommend it for
anybody it's not easy to do man I mean
the the even that like I said I there's
no like Iceland or Japan trip in my near
future alone but like I've seen I told
the story before and I tell the story in
detail with pictures in the book of
mythicality
about my intention to go off the Joshua
Tree by myself for just a weekend and
it's like it's in kind of what I know
talking about in the book is how with
all my intention to like be like I know
I don't get to do this very often I've
got a weekend alone I'm going to like
set some goals for myself I want to come
away with some sort of like epiphany
about something because I've got this
time to myself and then I basically just
ended up taking a shirtless selfie of
myself and posting it on Instagram yes
that's what that trip amounted to did
spring my ankle but I took a half naked
selfie because I didn't go in with the
right intentions but you got a good
story in a book ID I did but I've
actually thought about he's funny cuz I
don't know I don't know if I've been on
edge lately or whatever but Jesse the
other day was like you know I really
feel like you might need to go away for
a weekend by yourself I think you know
we just bit more no comment we've been
working so hard she was like I think you
know I think you could probably use that
you can use that again but I don't have
any I don't have any specific plans to
do that but I'm like I'm i if I do it
again I have to go in with more
intention like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna be on the internet I'm gonna take
my phone because I might need my phone
for survival navigation purposes mm-hmm
but like I'm not gonna be on social
media and I'm not gonna be taking naked
pictures of myself I might do that but
I'll keep it to myself that'll be from
me yeah you
for the internet good but but it's
certainly I appreciate you know you're
sure an experience with us because I
mean it convinces even more what a
mythical idea it is to do that so I you
know I'll III think I will always
remember the imagery of you pulling up
the Google map and then deciding all
right I've decided to do something in
spite of fears questions preconceived
notions and now it's just a question of
okay what's this what are the specifics
because I know it's going to happen
that's certainly very mythical so we
applaud you sir and we're glad to have
you here as part of the mythical team
yes and here's to you mythical beast who
are bringing up Google Maps right now
looking at all that ocean finding the
islands and the continents and the
cities that you might point to point at
one of those and then go stay in a
hostel there but learn to correctly
pronounce the name of the place you're
gonna stay the first night and bring an
ankle brace and some ice I'm gonna go
take a nap
[Music]